Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Uh,
she was in there.
I never worked with shoes in there.
Great,
great person.
Freak freak.
It's crazy how this fucking sport just chews people up.
You think you're on top and then it's gone and it's over.
But the casual fan doesn't kill.
That's why that paper you a cell because the casual fan goes,
oh,
that's the girl who worked Ronda Rousey.
That's the argument from a Gregor versus Floyd Bates fucking happening.
That's happening,
but it's going to happen.
See,
so McGregor,
it held a press conference last night,
sold out arena.
5,000 tickets sold out the on the mic.
He goes,
fuck the UFC.
Fuck everything.
He said,
fuck boxing you.
And he goes to the next fight,
the next fight.
Me Verse Floyd.
He was fully get it fucking done.
And then he goes,
I'm going to do it with or without the UFC.
And they told Dana that.
He goes,
good luck with that.
Good luck getting that done with that.
He believes it with the Ali Act.
He can actually do it because it's a different sport.
He has the money to hire the lawyers to try it.
Well it's,
it is an interesting argument because it's not MMA boxing.
So if it's boxing it's not,
he doesn't have a contrast.
She should just promote it anyways and work together with Floyd and say,
well done.
It's not just with Floyd,
it's with McGregor promotions now that he's got his own thing.
That's the key to promote because they don't want it.
They don't want to have a third middleman in Dana white cause you have Conor
McGregor promotions,
Floyd Mayweather it,
and then the UFC,
they don't want to give the,
you is going to become what boxing is.
It's going to become that because it's star driven.
Like all things like music,
hate,
like comedy,
like everything.
It's going to stay star driven.
And when it's star driven like that,
guys like Connor who are legitimate stars,
they have the leverage and they're going to manipulate that leverage.
They're gonna utilize that leverage and we're going to see what happened.
Especially right now I just started,
we've ever had,
it's a reality star driven,
but it is a reality.
Why is it?
Why do you hate that?
Because it's always been like that in boxing.
Well,
right.
I mean that's how they make the hundred million dollar paydays.
He's a purist and real quick.
Yeah,
me too.
But I would love to see Conor was Floyd.
Rob,
rob and I were talking about fights.
This dude said he's never seen a fight.
He doesn't lie.
Every single fight.
I've hated a lot of fun.
You see Kimbo and Donna.
Okay.
That you got right to it.
Quick.
Right to the point that maybe there maybe.
I did see one seen some shitty fight,
fight,
and he was like,
I liked
each other out.
Gracie's last bite on Bella coil cable.
We were talking about it.
I liked it too.
This is what I liked about that all bullshit aside.
How Gracie fought a fucking killer.
I mean that guy knocked out Joe Schilling twice.
He knocked him out and kickboxing and he knocked him out in MMA.
He's a fucking beast.
He's a very dangerous striker.
He's a very big guy and he's fucking scary.
He's a blaster and how it,
nothing.
No,
no,
no.
He avoided getting knocked down.
Your boy who's a beast in new mouth because he scared.
He was worried about getting taken down.
It was scary to get strangled.
And what were you scared of is what happened in the last minute of the last
round when I did take him down past his garlic butter,
fucking mounted him and had him in a bad spot.
Haluk was going to fuck him up if that fight kept going,
if that was in the first minute of the first round,
how might fight with fuel to do it because he hit the guy that you guys think
that was entertaining fight.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
That's great.
And you hated Kim overs.com that was more hate it.
I didn't hate him,
but it was not a high level fight.
I hated the fact that people were watching it on TV and both guys were severely
unconditioned.
There were severely out of shape.
Like,
no,
I didn't.
His heartbeat stopped the hip Revit enough.
That's true.
Is that some of that is him,
but uh,
no.
I,
when I think about it,
honestly,
I hated what the fight was about,
but I love the fight,
the dynamic of what's happening between these two human beings in combat.
I mean dot.
And Kimbo.
Yeah.
Even that one,
the dynamic between them is different than every other fight in their case,
Mike,
because chose Mike.
Jamie.
Yeah.
If it was my student out until I was about,
are you intrigued by the,
by the time Mcgregor,
Floyd Mayweather.
I said as if Conor McGregor could actually box with Floyd Mayweather.
Mcgregor cannot box with Floyd Mayweather,
but Conor Mcgregor's what?
The only goal that he could have the workable idea as a backdoor hack.
Something where being unwilling to make it a boxing match.
He is fighting him with two hands.
But boxing is not the definition of fighting with two hands.
Find a hack,
find a back door.
What would Tim Ferriss do if Tim,
if you said,
hey,
Tim Ferris,
how,
how do you beat Floyd Mayweather with a guy who's never pushed him off the stand
yet?
You'd want someone else's idea and regurgitate.
Yeah.
It's not that easy.
No,
it's not.
But Mcgregor has found the disruption.
Okay.